be mindful I don't talk a lot about
spiritual stuff on this channel but this
is something that's helped me and I
wanted to share it with you guys today I
know a lot of entrepreneurs are stressed
out working to the max feel like you
have no time for yourself feel like your
life might be out of control and a great
way to combat that is to be mindful
mindfulness is when you take care and
you are careful with the things in your
life you're not throwing things around
you're not stressing and rushing from
one thing to the next you take specific
action and you take it carefully let me
break it down with a store that might
help this is what helped me I remember
reading the story about a monk who was
taking care of his ropes the ropes that
he wore and some of the robes are over a
hundred years old and been passed on
from month to month to month and the
robes are sooo great quality but what
also helped was how he took care of the
robes and how mindful he was when he was
putting them on when he was taking them
off when he was washing them he was
really careful who's really mindful
about it and as a result the robes
lasted a long time and I looked at my
life when I was in with my clothes and
you know I got ready in five minutes or
less you know like throw on underwear
throw on pants Jenna a leg through and
they're throwing a shirt you know when I
got home and I was changing throw it off
chuck it into the pile put on a hanger
there was no no care at all and as a
result that my clothes didn't last as
long and so now what I try to do I try
to do i'm not always great at it but
what i try to do is when i'm changing
when I'm washing my clothes when I'm
folding them when I'm putting my clothes
away I try to take a little bit extra
time I try to be more careful try to be
more mindful in how I'm putting it on
you
jan my leg through my endure anymore you
know I try to put it on carefully and
you have you thinking why I have and
this is crazy like what are you talking
about how does this help my business and
it helps because this is a simple
exercise that you can try for the next
week and what I found worked for me was
when I started doing this it started to
apply to other areas of my life as well
and I would be more mindful and
everything that I was doing and again
it's not always a hundred percent you
know I'm not a Buddhist monk but I found
that it gave me more patience it gave me
more focus it helped me not stress out
as much and those all apply to my life
but also to my business so give it a
shot you know give it a shot you've got
one week to test it out just be mindful
with your clothes put them on carefully
take them off carefully wash them
carefully hang them up put them away
carefully worst case scenario you know
your clothes are a little bit better off
for that week and you've tried this
crazy new thing best-case scenario is
teaching you more focus that have less
stress to be more mindful and that'll
have a significant impact across your
life and your business so give it a shot
and believe those are watching if you
have tried other methods of being
mindful in and if it's had an impact on
your life or business somehow leave it
in the comments below I'd love to hear
from you give it a thumbs up if you
liked this video click on my face to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon
you